hello dr. fair this is eric cornell you
and I have something in common we both
want a Nobel Prize as every Nobel Prize
winner knows the serious research
oftentimes isn't done by the principal
investigators not by the professor's but
by the graduate students I wonder if you
would mind sharing with us an anecdote
an interesting story about one of your
favorite graduate students yes will tell
a story is doing of the day of the first
observation of the giant
magnetoresistance so I was expecting
some large effects from the sample we
had prepared but I am alway present and
modest and so I prefer to be pessimistic
so we are using to record the change of
the resistance ax while recorder
analogic XY recorder and so I say the
students put the scale to observe an
effect of one or two persons so I was
present so so she indeed put a scare
like I say but then there's a pan of
this extra jumpin and went off when I
say out of the out of the scale and so I
say okay you can increase the scale by a
factor of two or three again the pen
jump out of the scale and so finally the
students are the other two several times
to change the scale and finally we could
observe the four change of scale of self
the very large giant magnetoresistance
and and so it was the story of the first
observation of the gmr